je m'appelle augustin cazals 43 ans
marié un enfant
responsable d' agences immobilières dans
le logement social et conseiller
départemental du canton cette saint
benoît à la plaine des palmistes
le canton 7 saint benoît un compote les
quartiers de la rivière des roches bra
kanon brin fusible aubier abondance et
ça va se terminer à la plaine des
palmistes je suis attaché à ce canton
parce que je suis né dans ce conte ans
et j'ai grandit également dans le canton
je souhaite m'engager dans le domaine de
l'amélioration de l'habitat parce que en
travaillant dans le logement social
depuis plus de 20 ans j'ai constaté que
pour les particuliers c'est un domaine
qui est présent souffrance un autre
sujet qui me tient à coeur c'est
également le domaine sportif puisque au
niveau du sport j'estime que le secteur
s on est très en retard comparée à
d'autres villes de l'île de la réunion
alors je me suis engagé au niveau du
département puisque le département est
l'une des plus grosses collectivités si
à la réunion et sa compétence première
est la compétence sociale l'amélioration
de l'habitat les personnes âgées les
personnes en situation d'handicap
l'éducation fait partie des compétences
du département l'agriculture entre
autres donc je me suis engagé à ce
niveau là pour essayer de faire avancer
les choses au niveau de la réunion et
surtout pour le secteur reste pour mon
canton qui est un canton que j'estime
qui a été très longtemps en souffrance
au niveau de l'action sociale